welcome back to new rockstars i'm
jessica clements and i'm so pumped to
talk to you about the third episode
because there's so many fun things that
happened we got long bean just long long
just long and more new characters to
learn from and as always she-hulk coming
into herself plus megan the mother effin
stallion it's like jessica gao said
jessica clemens of new rockstars we have
an episode for you and i said bless up
baby also i'd like to mention because
i've forgotten and i'm so sorry our
great partners over at the epic hero
shop just released their green justice
merch line inspired by shehul it's got
several different t-shirt designs
including the newest limited edition
latest obsession shirt lady justice
they're also dropping lines inspired by
house of the dragon and or rings of
power in the coming weeks when purchased
you get an opportunity to get a shout
out and such from vosmt and mtni on
inside marvel what fun okay now let's
get into our episode three breakdown jen
is storming the dodc like she's been
there a hundred times as she walks
through the lasers i noticed the a113 on
the wall and immediately went to a113
pixar number if you don't know it's the
classroom number used by a ton of pixar
alumni at the california institute of
the arts and it's hidden in a ton of
pixar movies it's featured in spider-man
homecoming avengers end game guardians
of the galaxy so it's not just an
animation they can project videos and
images on a mill's prison walls which i
think is pretty insane and futuristic
but they do this almost in every marvel
movie so it's not too new emil discloses
pretty late i might add that wong forced
him out of prison and he knew wong's
complete title probably because wong's
been introducing himself as the sorcerer
supreme since no way home and i stand
for it be proud wong we see wong's mock
linkedin account nikki and juan's mutual
connection is bruce i love this
confirmation that avengers can have
linkedin accounts because i'm sure tony
had one he's so proud to be the sorcerer
supreme he also marked full-time
librarian at karma taj for 11 years and
a target sales associate for nine years
so if my math is correct give or take
because we all know no one updates their
linkedin maybe just me wong was
appointed sorcerer supreme in 2018
following the blip 11 years before that
as a librarian so that's 2007. but for
nine years he was a target sales
associate so from 1998 to approximately
2007 wong was training at carmitage but
also side gigged as a target employee go
off king jen breaks the fourth wall and
here we hear a little transitional
twinkle before it
i know you can't wait to see long i get
it which we haven't really heard yet
it's hard to describe but it's a sort of
futuristic synthy wave passing between
your left and right speakers it's
similar to the noise tony's machine
model makes an end game when it was a
successful run it seems like jen knows
it's the wcu also known as the wong
cinematic universe because she wants us
to remember this show isn't about him or
bruce or blonsky it's she-hulk baby also
jen if that ain't a self-driving car
keep your hands 10-2 we get the pass by
effect introducing news los angeles now
announcing jennifer walters is
representing emil blonsky he used the
photos straight out of 2008's incredible
hulk below the headline reads
super-powered influencer titania speaks
out about latest legal troubles
confident her legal team will make it go
away which shows that her altercation
with jen has not smoothed over in the
slightest we see the tattle news frame
like entertainment news an anchor played
by amanda salas who also is the
entertainment anchor for good day la in
another pass by effect we see just how
popular she-hulk is right now on what i
assume is youtube she's covered under
the tag she-hulk news and superhero
she's being talked about on despiata
daily news there's theory videos on
she-hulk not being real a hoax
conspiracy theories on this poor woman
dear lord is this how i sound all the
time i hope not they've also already
started calling her the big green woman
on the internet this girl has gone viral
if you want to call being called a big
green woman viral yeah i would i'll
quickly explain the ups and downs of all
she-hulk's online threads first we get a
nonsensical man i made that up played by
rory asplin who was featured in episode
1 of she-hulk as a stunt performer i
think he might have been the guard on
the right we get mixed sexist comments
from people like dom the bounty hunter
hard seltzer steve and darby don't care
tick tocks emojis memes more unwanted
male commentary and i'm about to hulk
out just reading and listening to them
all she's being covered on the news the
conversation with jefferson coop we meet
blonsky's former attorney gideon wilson
played by jason turner who a we didn't
see in the incredible hulk or anything
else and b is sam wilson's brother in
the comics gideon first appears in world
war hulk gamma corpse number one he was
sam and sarah's older brother when he
joined the gamma corps they were
basically made to take down the hulk he
was super supportive of his brother
becoming captain america but gideon's
story in the comics is super rough his
son died from aids and he took his anger
basically out on the hulk it's pretty
sad but
it's a it's a good comics it's good
comic run but in mcu he doesn't really
exist that we know of to sam and sarah's
knowledge it was just the two of them
but maybe gideon as the oldest left far
before sam and sarah could remember
there's a lot of theories that could be
made but i think it's important to note
that they chose gideon wilson as the
character to prosecute abomination in
the past rather than anyone else if
you're full of chivalry and really want
to address someone as lord and lady
established titles can make it official
established title is a project based on
a historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english they let
people buy as little as one square foot
of dedicated land so they can call
themselves as lord or lady and return
established titles commits to planting a
tree it's a fun way to help preserve the
beautiful woodlands and biodiversity of
scotland while raising funds to support
global conservation efforts established
titles works with the global charity
trees for the future and one tree
planted to help them plant a tree for
every order plus for those with scottish
heritage it is a great way to connect
with your family roots your title pack
gives you a numbered plot of dedicated
land on a private estate in edelson
scotland and an official certificate
with a crest you can change your name on
the credit cards plane tickets and
dating profiles get a couple pack for
you and your partner with adjoining
plots of land you can literally have
this gift ready in five minutes and
here's a detail you missed this is
philip's title
but i'm gonna get my own because
established titles told me that the
first 200 people purchasing a title pack
using our link will effectively be next
to each other within a few minutes
walking distance depending on how many
of you want to become a lord or a lady
we can build our little new rock star's
kingdom take that philip use code
rockstars to get an additional 10 off go
to establishtitles.com rockstars to get
your gifts now take it away jessica
we're introduced to mallory book
officially played by renee ellis
goldsberry if you remember this is the
woman from hamilton who's an amazing
singer but also a phenomenal actress
just a reminder in the comics she was an
amazing lawyer but just a rival to jen
and superman i didn't really like her
it's revealed dennis was dating a
shapeshifter who made himself look like
megan the stallion and jen does my job
breaking it down who she is so i don't
have to sorry you thought you were
dating megan the stallion uh multiple
grammy award winner mega star megan the
sound what part of shape shifter did you
not get
you thought she drove up a sub more
specifically a shape-shifting light elf
named roona from new asgard who we later
found out is the daughter of an elven
diplomat of asgard and now new asgard
the light elves have been pretty good to
most knowledge they're native to alphine
one of the nine realms conquered by odin
wong appears behind him it looks like a
living room there's a couch coffee table
some chairs and nice lights it's a mood
sitting room it's probably a combination
cat's out the bag wong forced
abomination out of prison because he
needed a worthy opponent to train to be
the sorcerer supreme wong mentioned that
he's aware of the spell that wiped
everyone's memory of knowing peter
parker because doctor strange basically
had to ask him permission to do it if
you remember after acknowledging wong
left saying just leave me out of this he
also adds it's very messy which could
refer to all those unanswered questions
people have about it wong goes on to
share some advice saying we'll send him
to the mirror dimension the parallel
dimension that allowed people to
practice magic and fight you remember in
doctor strange then offering the shadow
dimension which i don't think is the
shadow realm necessarily but he meant
the dark dimension where we last saw
clea and doctor strange headed to in
multiverse and madness we get a shot of
pug's laptop he has you screen aka
youtube up we're watching the megan the
stallion imposter fight at celebrate
with a qr code on the right videos like
pony imposter thinks it's a stallion
iron man 3's honest reviews i really
want to click on it malgrado tay a short
film written and directed by kevin
rodingen who does vfx for she-hulk
series kevin i'm sorry for butchering
your name but i'm still going to respect
you here's his photo and my favorite
bear fight once pug recognizes it's runa
and not dennis we get the jaws like zoom
in it's so funny to me maybe because
while he's quiet dennis thinks it's
because he has a tesla cyber truck you
know those like super ugly cars that
tesla
we're back to the dodc prison the same
red lasers that jen has to walk through
to see emil are outside were with knbs
news the anchor is played by real life
journalist sharon reed the man with
k-a-j-e-3
asked jen if it's true she's been
rejected by the avengers and in the show
we know that's a blatant lie even in the
comics she's left in return a ton of
times but has never been rejected by
them she's been fired yes but that's a
different kind of rejection if you know
what i mean we meet the soul mates and
boy was i right blair ruth marta sheila
alejandra yvonne and nicolette his
better eighths blonsky plans on making a
meditation retreat on his plot of land
which possible spoilers i'm so sorry i
think we saw in the trailers already at
what i assumed was the group therapy
blontie's first preliminary witness is
the literacy program guy sean holt
played by brooke brown the prison
counselor amy chance played by jennifer
van horn and the crying guard carl
cowart played by robert stevens wayne
now according to jen's documents they
don't match what was assigned in the
credits this could just be a little
mistaken post or jen genuinely confused
with their job i think it's the first
one which is no biggie i just have to
acknowledge it and if at this part you
were like i don't know what a shiv is
it's a shank which i keep in my sock at
all times
it's a breakdown if someone doesn't know
what a shiv is i have to explain it wong
says this have you ever heard of a comet
insinuating it might be a little longer
until a mill truly gets its verdict but
also the kumite covers a lot of things
it's one of the three main sections of
karate training it's not justin
bloodsport or that one episode of the
boondocks when we switch to our b story
we get a better look at judge price
played by george bryant and roona's
lawyer lauren jesper played by ruth
kaufman when this is said by judge price
she may have diplomatic immunity in new
asgard but we are not in new ascot it's
a tricky answer mainly because i'm not a
lawyer but according to the united
nations treaty collection modern
diplomat immunity was codified as
international law and the vienna
convention on diplomatic relations which
has been ratified by the us and norway
which is home to new asgard so basically
we agreed in article 9 that we the u.s
can consider someone as unwelcome but we
still have to let their home state know
if we don't hear back in a certain
period of time or they refuse we can ask
them to leave the us or we can cancel
the diplomats visa and bar them and
their families from returning to united
states ever again so when judge price
said that he could be referring to the
fact that new asgard is its own country
within norway and has different
diplomatic immunity or maybe because
runa has it in new asgard does it mean
the us gave it to her to be fair new
asgard isn't that old and i don't know
how the un handles previously signed
treaties with new cities within old
countries but i assume they fall under
norway's jurisdiction if your lawyer
just hit me up or if you have better
knowledge of international law just
stand up please in the chat
root is this speech which i think we all
remember from thor ragnarok and it's
perfect timing excuse me your honor but
asgard is not a place it is a people
therefore thor's inspirational speeches
are not admissible in court
there's god is not a place
it's a people
a meal turns into abomination and he is
just so gentle picking up his shoes as
we know this abomination favors more to
the comics hence his little gilly gills
what i really hate though in this scene
is how much his partner swoon over him
changing into abomination it just makes
me want to throw myself out of a moving
car you know it's just like
why and then he's waving at them in the
reflection it's so
uh i don't want to yuck anyone's young
but it's weird
so currently wong is a wanted man a
criminal for helping facilitate a
prisoner escape let's keep that noted
because wang is now a wanted man the
knbs news 6 reporter mentions this is
there any truth to the rumors you got
your powers from a mafia hit gone wrong
which happened in the original comics
crime boss nicholas trask crew shot and
seriously injured jen warranting a blood
transfusion from bruce giving her her
abilities in the back we see kcav 35
which we haven't seen in the mcu but is
the new station for breaking bad i'm
re-watching breaking bad right now
the app on nikki's phone is snafu which
is a satirical comic book from the 1950s
marvel comics made it to mimic mad
magazine written by stan lee catch here
when gem breaks the fourth wall these
duo don't notice but hulk noticed in the
first episode so maybe it's like the
family shared dna can recognize it
another anecdote we can see more of as a
series goes on but worth noting as the
idea that only certain folks can see it
seeing as you can get up to three years
in jail or prison for false
impersonation in california 60 days is a
great punishment but again not a lawyer
please don't use me as a cause to any of
your crimes people i will freak out i
screamed so loud so loud when megan the
stallion presented herself in that full
church pink get up and fandom match that
person next to her is just as shook as i
am signature
included
so when dennis mentioned making sure
runa could never trick anyone again with
her powers it was right on the nose that
jen would think about using the
inhibitor remember bruce had it in the
first episode now this tricky tricky
instrument could open the door to the
mutant registration act we saw in x-men
seeing as we're already acknowledging
mutants exist in the mcu basically the
immune registration act identified and
tracked all mutants but could set up any
vigilante to target registered mutants
regardless capturing people and using an
inhibitor immediately sounds like a fine
idea until someone is falsely prosecuted
wrongfully imprisoned or killed while
holding it's not as easy as jen thinks
and this could set up shop for a very
dangerous game on citizen news tonight
the news anchor is played by bob
decastro who is also on fox 11 la she
finally interviews and is a giant step
for she-hulk and i'm so proud no pun
intended i just love her and i'm glad at
how she's doing in the show when gets
home she gets jumped by this man in a
yellow helmet and this guy who has
purple emitting glow from his gloves and
this guy with a blue emitting crowbar
and this man at the end has a pinkish
ball and chain we later find out that
one of the men is named thunderball and
oh baby wait till you get a gander at
this crew now you might have seen them
in avengers the earth mightiest heroes
fighting thor or an ultimate spider-man
but they are the super villain team
known as the wrecking crew see the w's
on their shirts why do they have shirts
for their crimes their story is pretty
wild and chaotic dirk garthwaite aka the
wrecker broke into loki's home for the
crowbar and right as loki was getting
powers from carnella dirk got in the way
and got it he later fought thor and his
powers transferred from him to his
crowbar but in prison he met
ex-physicist elliot franklin aka
thunderball brian koleski aka piledriver
and ex-army sergeant henry camp aka
bulldozer when they broke free they
retrieved the magical crowbar they
really stood in the lightning storm
pulled a shazam and each got a piece of
its power they each have distinct
weapons they use so bulldozer has his
armored helmet neck shoulder covers
wrecker has his crowbar thunderball has
a ball and chain and piledriver has huge
hands that are super strong they've
fought in secret wars they've even
assisted in hood's criminal syndicate
during the scroll invasion so ultimately
we could see more of them since we're
headed in that direction already but
they did steal these weapons from an
asgardian construction worker so maybe
the origins may change a little their
backstory and she-hulk could also be
different from the comics but these
characters in the comics are around all
the time fighting everyone and usually
losing now for the real question who's
their boss and here's my theories in the
comics they've worked under the hood who
we know is coming into ironheart and
they worked under baron zemo who led the
masters of evil and fought the
thunderbolts so those two characters are
two big deals because they're getting
them in another series of movie anyways
the leader from incredible hulk he was
super excited to work with banner and
with his blood he could do a lot maybe
getting she-hulk would be even easier or
lastly they could be working for leap
frog which hey is a stretch but it would
be fun to see a more rich version of
leapfrog trying to make up for what his
dad couldn't and he has his own team of
goons the episode closes yanaka sees the
power i love this song this is the first
piece of new material since 2019 and
they even said in an interview we want
you to get lost in a feeling of strength
and empowerment when listening to this
song and i want that to be completely
true though jen looks defeated in this
last scene looking at her reflection it
feels like the ending of every euphoria
episode i just want this to be the look
of a woman who just recognized yeah
maybe her old life is over but she's a
superhero now verse thinking i can't do
this i don't want to do this i want her
confident i just want her courageous we
get a new courtroom illustration of
blonsky on his release shuttle with his
seven partners happily crying and waving
him off goodbye we get nikki's first
trap with the books in a library to
catch one's attention dennis taking
megan the stallion out on a very
luxurious date assuming that's not
actually megan but maybe roona megan the
stallion is jen's latest client and let
me tell you i've never been happier this
is like watching your two very best
different friends meet and become best
friends this is like the first time you
put peanut butter and chocolate together
this is my two favorite things coming
together if they somehow put anime in
this i just explode and to top it all
off they're twerking they close the
episode to body by megan the stallion
and if you told me five years ago kevin
feige would approve of the hot ebony aka
tina snow aka megan the stallion would
be canon in the mcu i'd say
are you lying oh that's everything i
spotted in the third episode of she-hulk
follow me on instagram and twitter at
lulu underscore clemens both new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
you